hope
ready
step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready
step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
running step
ready step
ready step
running step
ready step
ready step
ready stop
ready stop
ready step
ready step
ready step
ready step
right step
right step
step
ready step
ready step
right
order
[Music]
you
you
you
changed
yeah like sometimes i'll watch
documentaries
okay
oh
uh
recently
uh
[Music]
why did you the announcement
rise
uh
okay
uh
[Music]
um
oh
oh
[Music]
so
so
okay
so
so
what
oh
so
ladies and gentlemen please remain
standing for the invocation
delivered by house chaplain margaret
gren kibben
would you pray with me
[Music]
holy and eternal god
to this grand hall and from across the
country
we come to this moment with deep
gratitude
for the life and legacy of senator
robert joseph dole
we are grateful
that in his selfless devotion to you and
to these united states he has revealed
to us
what moral and faithful service should
be
as we honor his 79 years of standing up
for what's right
we stand before you to offer our
heartfelt prayers
we ask that the influence senator dole
has had on countless people
leaders
neighbors and strangers alike
would not be without long-lasting
fruit in extolling senator dole's
unequaled integrity
disarming humor
and deep compassion
may we be inspired to reach into the
depths of our own small town virtues
or our big city bravado
to emulate this plane spoken statesman
this decorated war hero
this your humble servant
we commend this tribute to you that you
would enable us to find just the right
words to honor this righteous man
that you would encourage us to imitate
this inspiring servant
that you would equip us to carry forth
with the faith of this faithful leader
we pray this in the strength of your
name
amen
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats
ladies and gentlemen the honorable mitch
mcconnell republican leader of the
united states senate
uh
on april 14
1969
senator bob dole
delivered his first floor speech
he said quote
the task ahead
is monumental
and this was before bob knew he'd end up
leading a conference
of 53 senators
years later after he had become leader
bob described his senate management
challenges
with his trademark width
if i'd known he said we were going to
win control the senate
we'd run better candidates
i swear bob could have made it as a
stand-up comic
but in that maiden speech
bob was earnest
he was already championing a signature
cause
helping americans
with disabilities
the task ahead is monumental he said
but i'm confident that there are forces
in america ready and willing
to meet the challenge
bob dole himself
was certainly proof of that
that made the speech came 24 years to
the day after he sustained
his combat wounds
in italy
bob had already risen to a monumental
task
he'd taken the fight
to the nazis
and he nearly paid for it
with his life
through all his decades in public
service
bob dole knew exactly
where he came from
a son of
dust bowl hardship
who was laser focused
on food security
and rural issues
a wounded
warrior he spent decades carrying
fellow veterans
and americans with disabilities
on his shoulders
bob was the last of the greatest
generation to run for president
but he was never stuck in the past
his roots ran deep
but he was always looking
to new horizons
from that first speech
through his years in leadership
through bob's incredibly active
retirement
in name only
he built brighter futures
for millions
bob was blessed with long life
to watch this legacy take effect
but that was no accident
bob liked to joke that he planned for
longevity
by closely studying our most senior
colleagues
he had a whole comedy routine about how
he had tried to copy strom thurman's
eating habits
strong
takes a shrimp
i take a shrimp
if he eats a banana
i eat a banana
but the real engine behind bob's 98
remarkable years was his love
his love for elizabeth
and for robin
for public service
for kansas
and for america
today we honor the amazing life
that love created
and we thank god
the source of all love
both for bob's incredible journey here
in this life
and for the fact that he has entered his
eternal reward
in the next
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the honorable
charles e schumer majority leader of the
united states senate
mr president
madam vice president
madam speaker leader mcconnell leader
mccarthy distinguished guests dear
colleagues and most importantly senator
elizabeth dole and robin
the scriptures say that we should quote
rejoice in our sufferings
knowing that suffering produces
endurance
and endurance produces character
and character produces hope
today
we pay tribute to a remarkable leader
over the course of his life knew more
than his fair share of suffering
who turned that suffering into endurance
whose endurance
became central to his character
and whose character
whose essential goodness leaves us with
hope
hope that we will continue to see good
men and women
in this country
like the one to whom we say goodbye
today
to pay tribute to senator bob dole is to
honor someone who redefined and elevated
what it means
to serve country
by 21
bob had given more of himself than most
of us given a lifetime
and he and then he kept going for 77
years
after that and my god it was 77 years
well spent
at 27 he was elected to state politics a
decade later he came to congress
followed promptly with an election to
the senate
sixteen years later bob dole was
majority leader
remaining in party leadership until his
final run for president
in 1966
1996
the years were well spent however
not because of his titles
but because of what he accomplished
today tens of millions of americans
veterans the elderly the disabled and
millions of kids across the country are
better off
because of bob dole
he never lost his roots as a principled
pragmatic kansas republican
and bob never hesitated to work with
democrats to get things done
from joining senator mcgovern on federal
nutrition programs to working with my
former colleague senator moynihan to
protect social security
to helping pass the americans with
disability act was senators kennedy and
harkin
bob dole was a champion of those whose
lives were marred by struggle
who came not from citadels of privilege
but from humble origins like his own
in his memoir senator dole wrote that
supporters were sometimes too surprised
to hear that of all his accomplishments
in the senate
reforming social security
was his greatest pride along with
passing the ada
i'm sure that surprises a few of us here
today but i doubt those who knew the bob
dole of russell kansas the man whose
family lived for years in their own
basement so they could rent out their
house
who was county attorney had to approve
his grandfather's welfare checks each
month
whose recovery from war was made
possible only after his hometown
pooled money to pay for surgery
i imagine that those who knew this side
of bob dole understood that no matter
how high he climbed up the ranks
he never forgot the reason he entered
public service
and of course he did it all with
unmistakable acerbic wit
honed and refined over the years as he
worked as a soda jerk in the local
drugstore
bob and i never worked together in the
senate but i was not spared his famous
ribbing don't worry bob
it's safe to be between me and the
cameras today
in closing
i want to bring back an enduring image
of bob that took place nine years ago
as we said goodbye to another colleague
lying in this same rotunda
none of us will ever forget the strength
and honor of bob with elizabeth at his
side
standing and saluting danny in a way
one last time
bob used to tell the story of him and
danny recovering from war wounds at
percy jones army hospital in battle
creek michigan
as they recuperated they discussed their
futures with bob telling danny he
planned to run for local office and
eventually the united states senate
at the time danny had a different path
in mind for himself but like bob's plan
ran for office and event eventually was
actually elected to the senate before
bob after danny was sworn in one of the
first things he did was call his old
friend and said bob i'm in the senate
where are you
now
as bob approaches the pearly gates
let us take comfort he can reunite
with his old friend
once again
in the meantime
let the rest of us carry on
in thanksgiving and unending celebration
of the life of this incredible
american statesman
ladies and gentlemen the honorable nancy
pelosi
speaker of the united states house of
representatives
good morning
mr president it is a sad and official
honor to join our colleagues
and the leadership in welcoming you and
the first lady and the vice president to
the united states capital you come as
senator dole's
long-time colleague personal friend
and as president
and we reckon as we recognize the life
and service of the honorable
robert j
thanks to the leaders and members of our
congressional community here with us
this morning
we all come to pay tribute and on their
behalf
i extend a special welcome to senator
joel's loving and dedicating dedicated
partner in service
elizabeth senator elizabeth dole and his
dear daughter robin
it's sad for all of us
as speaker of the house there's a
special source of pride for us in the
house that senator dole began his
congressional career in the house of
representatives
and it is fitting that as we gather in
the capital rotunda home to american
heroes memorialized in marvel and bronze
to pay tribute to an extraordinary
patriot
once before we gathered here in the
rotunda
in his name in 2018
it was my personal and official honor to
join our colleagues and the leadership
it will help bestow upon him the
congressional gold medal
the highest honor congress can bestow
on that day as we do on this sad day we
recognize senator doles among the
pantheon of patriots honoring his duty
he always talks a duty to our nation
with courage dignity and integrity
as i stand here and see
his coffin on the catapult that was
built for lincoln
with that flag drop draped over and i'm
sure many of you here will agree
it's hard to think of anyone who was
more worthy to have a flag draped over
his coffin because of his great
patriotism to our country
on both sides of the aisle on both sides
of the capitol across the country
senator dole was widely respected for
his legendary service
on the battlefields of world war ii
his inspiring resilience after
recovering from grievous war wounds his
principled leadership in the hallowed
halls of congress house
and senate
and his tireless
advocacy as an elder statesman
over the course of his storied career he
earned a reputation as a fighter for
hardworking american families a leader
who could be trusted as a man
of his word
working in a bipartisan way senator dole
addressed hunger in america by expanding
food stamps
fought for respect for people with
disabilities by enshrining essential
protections into the wall with the ada
again in a bipartisan way
he taught us
over time and all the time to respect
people
for what they can do and not judge them
for what they cannot
he advocated for our troops veterans and
hidden heroes who care for them
especially his alongside his beloved
wife elizabeth indeed the love
partnership
and prayerfulness
that senators bob and elizabeth dole
shared was a joy to behold and a
blessing to all of us
who know them
in recognition of his legendary career
senator dole received the 1997
metal presidential medal of freedom mr
president by a bestowed upon him by
president clinton
his electoral rival but certain
his fan upon receiving this medal
senator dole challenged us in his words
not to question american ideals or
replace them
but to act worthy of them
senator dole lived up to this challenge
devoting his entire life in service the
country he loved
and to our cherished national values for
which he fought
i remember when we were gathered here
honoring president george herbert bush
and how moved the whole nation was to
see senator dole
salute
president bush
so generous he was
so as we honor his life this morning let
us resolve to meet his challenge
but he said
to act worthy of our ideals
and carry on his mission
when we in congress gave senator dole
the congressional gold medal
he brought lust in receiving it he
brought luster to the award
just as his service and sacrifice
brought luster
to the congress and to the country
may it be a comfort to you robin
to elizabeth and all who love him that
all
so many people across the congress the
country
this beloved state of kansas that a
grateful nation mourns with them
and are praying for you at this sad time
may senator dole rest in the peace that
he deserves
ladies and gentlemen the honorable
joseph r biden jr
president of the united states
vice president harris
speaker pelosi
majority leader schumer
leader mcconnell
members of congress distinguished guests
most importantly
elizabeth and robin
i know this is not easy
thank you for letting us
do
this we meet here
in the very heart of american democracy
the capital of the united states of
america
to receive a hero
of that democracy for a
final time
robert joseph dole
he belongs here
in this place
in this temple of liberty to liberty and
to temple to possibilities
bob dole loved this capitol
it's where he served the nation
shaped by the figures that surround us
washington and jefferson
who set us on our path
abraham lincoln another man who from the
heartland of the country from once he
came
bob's hero
dwight david eisenhower
[Music]
martin luther king jr whom bob helped
pass legislation honoring
the great
civil rights leader with a federal
holiday bob stood up
and got that done
gerald ford
who served here and with whom bob
sought the vice president of the united
states
in a sentence
bob belongs here
he too
was a giant of our history
and that's not hyperbole it's real
of wit and grace
a principle of persistence
of courage and conviction
i had the great honor of serving with
bob as many of you around this casket
have i served with him for 25 years
he did have great wit they once asked
him why in god's name did he vote to
continue to fund amtrak
he said because if he didn't biden would
stay overnight and cause more trouble
i commuted every day
that's true
he was the deciding vote
well
you know uh
bob and i like many of us today we
disagreed on
a number of things but not on any of the
fundamental things
we still found a way to work together
we genuinely
we genuinely respected one another as
colleagues
as fellow americans it was real it
wasn't fake
and we became great friends
because bob deserves the final word
i'd like to read a portion of his final
message
that he left to the country
i hope we all listen to
in the days and weeks
months to come
and i quote bob dole
i cannot pretend that i have not been a
loyal champion of my party
but have always served my country best
when i did it
so first and foremost
as an american
or prioritize principles over party
humanity over a personal legacy
we do that we accomplish far more as a
nation
by leading with shared faith in each
other
we become
america at its best
he went on to say
a beacon of hope
a source of comfort in crisis
a shield against those who threaten
freedom
our nation
has certainly faced periods of division
but at the end of the day
we've always found ways to come together
we can find that unity again
then the message said end
of message
my fellow americans
america has lost
one of our greatest patriots
we may follow his wisdom i hope
and his timeless truth
that the truth of the matter is as
divided as we are the only way forward
for democracy is unity
consensus the only way
may we follow his wisdom
and his timeless truth
and reach consensus
the basic fundamental principles we all
agree on
god bless bob dole
may god bless america
and may god protect our troops
ladies and gentlemen staff sergeant
ethan green
u.s army chorus accompanied by mrs
joanna zorak greene
[Music]
great is my faithful
o
god my father
there is
[Music]
by compassions
they fail not
as
[Music]
great is my faithfulness
great is thy faithfulness
morning
my morning
new
mercies i see
have
needed thy hand hath provided
praise thy
faithfulness lord unto me
[Music]
pardon
forces
[Music]
blessing
are
mine with ten thousand
besides
[Music]
thy
faithfulness
grace
my
faithfulness
morning by
morning
new mercies
i see
[Music]
faithfulness lord unto me
grace thy faithfulness
prayed is my faithfulness
morning by morning
new mercies
[Music]
praise thy faithfulness
[Music]
is thy faithfulness
praise
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
ladies and gentlemen please rise for the
benediction
delivered by senate chaplain
barry c black
let us pray
great is your faithfulness
oh god
our father
so help us to see death
as you see it
not at the end
but the beginning
not a wall
but a doorway
not a dark road
but a path that leads
to eternal
light
and life
lord we will miss
the honorable robert joseph dole
but we thank you
for the blessed gift of memory
may our minds and hearts be filled
with the wonderful recollections
of his patriotism
courage
integrity
and wit
continue to be
for his beloved elizabeth
and precious robin
a refuge
and strength
now bless us all and keep us
make your face shine upon us
and be gracious to us
lift
the light of your countenance upon us
and give us
your shalom your peace
pray in the name of the one who said
i am
the resurrection
and the life
amen
ladies and gentlemen please remain at
your seats
until escorted to pay your respects
by the sergeants at arms staff
[Applause]
[Music]
so
so
uh
oh
foreign
oh
uh
so
so
okay
[ __ ]
[Music]
so
i
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
oh
uh
[Music]
okay
you